The A to Z of isms - Xenophobism
Xenophobia is a term used to describe
the fear and hatred
of the foreign "other".
It is a fear that the other,
the less deserving foreigner,
will take away your way of life.
Xenophobia has a long history.
The Romans and Greeks labelled those
outside their borders as barbarians
uncivilised brutes who needed
to be conquered
for fears of them
contaminating the empire.
And xenophobia is shaping
the political debate today.
In the campaign for Britain
to leave the EU,
we were starkly warned about the
threat of the hordes of foreigners
supposedly swarming to the border
of fortress Britain.
The prime minister at the time
of the vote, David Cameron,
ushered in Brexit, in part by badly
misjudging the power of xenophobia
when he assumed that people
would not ...
Across the Atlantic, Donald Trump
was elected on a wave of xenophobia
against the imagined ...
… supposedly pouring across
the border with Mexico.
"Build the wall" is the perfect
slogan of our xenophobic times.
Though it would be wrong to confuse
xenophobia with racism,
though the two are often related.
Racism is more than
the fear of the other.
It is a system of oppression based
on the belief that so-called races
are superior to others.
Just as much of the Brexit vote
was based on the desire to curb
white migration into Britain,
we have seen xenophobia in places
like South Africa,
where migrants from other
African countries
have been violently attacked
by other black people,
who are themselves poor
and lacking in opportunity.
It is a logic of scarce resources -
of the country being too full
to sustain the outsiders.
And a reminder that you can
be a victim of racism
and perpetrate xenophobia.
The Windrush scandal was caused
by the hostile environment
a xenophobic policy aimed at
squeezing out illegal immigrants
by making checks of documents routine
in all areas of life,
including work, education
and even visiting the doctor.
The unsurprising result was that
many, including those who had legally
come from the Caribbean post-war,
lost their jobs or were deported to
countries they had long left behind.
But it was also the logical
conclusion of decades of immigration
policy that purposefully
restricted immigration
from Britain's former colonies in the
Caribbean, Asia and Africa.
The expansion of freedom of movement
from Europe was a continuation
of welcoming white migration, whilst
closing the door on people of colour.
Xenophobic fears are easy to stir
when inequality increases.
The pain the so-called natives
feel through poverty and inequality
are turned onto the foreigner
trying to jump the queue.
It is no coincidence that following
that increased inequality
since the 2008 financial crisis,
xenophobia has been on the rise
across the world.
Thankfully there is a way
to tackle this trend.
When society is more equal
and provides for all,
there is no need to fear the other.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!